[Music]
along florida's space coast on the
atlantic ocean much of the attention is
focused on flight and rockets lifting
off from kennedy space center and cape
canaveral but nearby scientists have a
much more terrestrial concern how to
preserve a once thriving population of
oysters vital to the health of one of
the state's most ecologically important
waterways their effort is being
complicated by climate change lonnie
quinn reports
this is mosquito lagoon
it is a picture of tranquility
dolphins swimming by
and wading birds just watching over
things
many say it is the most biologically
diverse estuary on
the mainland united states
linda walters would know the university
of central florida professor has been
studying these waters for 24 years with
a focus on the eastern oyster they're
superstars there is no question about
that
they can handle all sorts of climatic
conditions do you think people around
the world don't have an appreciation for
an oyster i think everybody could do a
little bit better in appreciating
oysters they're not the prettiest animal
in the ocean
they don't have to be pretty they just
have to do a really important job
that job is filtering water
yes they look like rocks but these are
actually clusters of oysters
and each oyster sucks in 20 gallons of
water every day filled with algae and
muck and eventually spits out cleaner
and clearer water
everybody should care about oysters it's
just that simple they are one of the
most important species on this planet
for keeping our water clean
i see why you told me to wear an old
pair of sneakers these things are like
razor blades since 1943 mosquito lagoon
has lost 40 percent of its oyster reefs
within the boundaries of canaveral
national seashore
much of that due to boat wakes that
dislodge the oysters i see the healthy
part of the oyster reef which is this
dark color and right here where it's
white this is dead correct that's dead
and that's that's boat wake impact
walters had to help she and her team
have restored more than six percent of
the reefs but now
there's a new threat
mangroves are encroaching the
consequence of warming waters
it gets probably close to 95 96 in these
sorts of yeah 95 degrees
let me tell you linda we put bubbles in
here we got a jacuzzi
and that's how the mangrove trees prefer
it red mangroves will die when the air
temperatures dip below 24 degrees that's
known as a hard freeze and it prevents
the trees from moving to the north
but this area has not had one of those
in decades now over the last 20 years
the oysters in the mangroves are
competing for the same land and the
oysters are losing that battle this is a
dead reef but the mangroves they have
blown up they have gone up by 198
percent
now that may not be a bad thing
mangroves remove carbon from the air
they also provide a buffer during storms
but in this turf war professor walters
is rooting for the oyster
so in terms of climate change we always
talk about the average mean temperature
increasing but for you you're focusing
on that morning low temperature not
getting down as cold as it's been in the
past yeah that is a new field of
research that's called tropicalization
and we're finding it for lots of plants
lots of animals a single mangrove tree
produces hundreds to thousands of
propagules these are pre-germinated
seeds that look a little like a green
bean they float on the water and can
root on an oyster reef what you can see
right here is a new propagule so this
would have just shown up here and gotten
trapped amongst these clusters probably
within the last two weeks and this other
one here
is probably 20 years old at this point
and you can see that other new mangroves
are starting to grow right underneath
this they are just going to take up more
and more of the oyster reef as they all
start growing it looks like they coexist
nicely but the mangroves may be causing
the oysters to die off
ucf graduate student katherine harris
says it's likely it has something to do
with the chemistry of the trees
mangroves basically contribute to much
more acidic levels in the sediment and
over time that maybe starts to dissolve
the oyster shells and weaken the shells
which makes you know the base that the
oysters will grow on go away
one solution is for man to step in and
make more bases
this restored reef is a series of grids
that are made believe it or not from
potato chip waste so that's that's made
out of potatoes that's made out of
potatoes it is a starch material that is
considered a bioplastic
and these containers they shore up the
reef each one is filled with about 30
pounds of recycled oyster shells from
restaurants so we're keeping all of the
oysters out of landfills while creating
new oyster habitats and putting them
back out into the lagoon jessie wales of
the marine discovery center says the
recycled oyster shells act like a magnet
and attract tiny baby oysters to latch
on
since oysters are made out of calcium
carbonate as they leach off that calcium
carbonate baby oysters can sense it in
the water and they will actually find
these oyster bags and attach onto them
now what pile are we are we digging from
it's a simple process
that kind of doubles as cardio
go ahead and dump that baby right in
keep shaking it out camping on the
ground and we only need 1 399 more to go
to date the marine discovery center has
recycled more than 700 000 pounds of
oyster shells this entire back parking
lot is going to be full of oyster bags
by the time we're done
the center also restored this marsh now
they intended for it to be a marsh grass
nursery but mangroves took over here too
they got so thick we had to back out
where do the mangroves stop like they
don't go farther north than where
if you look at a textbook that's like 10
years old right here in mesquite lagoon
used to be the stop point for mangroves
at least for one species of mangoes red
mangroves and it used to be st augustine
which is about
70 miles north of here for black
mangroves now you see both species up
into georgia
where do you think they could be let's
say 10 years from now 10 years from now
i think north and south carolina are
going to have a lot more mangroves than
they do now which they pretty much have
none right now
and you will see the propagules the
seeds floating in the water much further
north because they won't be dying on the
way there
now no one can say for sure what that
will mean for coastal areas in the mid
and the north atlantic but right here in
mosquito lagoon
professor walters she finds plenty of
hope well with everything that's taken
place out here and having spent my
entire day with you you haven't stopped
smiling the whole day
for some reason you feel good about
things not bad about things
you know if you're gonna feel bad about
it you just have to find another job
there is so much willpower in
the united states and around the globe
to make our estuaries better lots of
people want to understand the problem
they want to help the problem and they
want to correct it for the future
generations is it fair to call you the
the oyster whisperer for cbs this
morning saturday i've been called the
oyster lady before ladies whether that's
nice or not ronnie quinn mosquito lagoon
florida
whenever we see stories like this i'm so
glad there are people that are so much
smarter than i am to figure something
out i always thought mangroves were a
good thing because they provided
protection against these battering
storms right yes it's where they are
though yeah that's what matters oyster
whisper i prefer oyster eater
there it is well i like that too we'll
take that